[Applause]
wins it tonight in Salt Lake City Utah
and Damian lillers
sticks the game winner what a shooting
display in the second half from
three-pointer race
Lillard and Mitchell and Tatum
Giannis has his coveted win
0-2 against LeBron as Captain and
Giannis finally can put one on the board
didn't he say hey I'm a great GM I'm a
great deal he came prepared this time
around at his blood had his picks and
got the dub
55 points
10 of 18 from downtown
what a display
and here's the three
to put the nail in the coffin
he sent the Rockets out of the playoffs
he sent the Thunder out of the playoffs
oh look at Chuck Chuck even knows
LeBron knows it's day and time as well
yep